do you miss me a smoke
i do
100
yeah and
i do and it's one of those things that i
got it i got the opportunity to go back
and and pick her up again on the flash
last year for they did this big
armageddon event where they brought in a
bunch of fun characters as the world was
ending as it always is somewhere in the
cw verse
and it was actually quite emotional um
because you know green arrow was one of
the last jobs i did before the pandemic
um barring the stand and a few other
things and getting to go back to the you
know vancouver film studios and put on
the suit again and it was such kind of a
bookmark of it felt like home and it was
the first time that in two and a half
years of
abnormal and weird and unknown
environment that we'd all been living in
i just felt normal again i felt like i
was home can you just jump into that
character again mia can you just jump
right into it without thinking can you
go from abigail walker to mia probably
and i think it's just because i know
there's characters that you just know
when you live in their skin for years
they're just a part of you and and
that's that's what i find exciting
that's why i love doing television so
you keep coming back to it what'd you do
so you don't mind guest starring you'll
always go back to be a guest star you'll
do whatever if you like it
oh yeah just put that green arrow signal
in the sky and i'll come running
really
oh yeah do you think you'll go back to
it do you think they'll bring you back
as mia i would hope so i mean i'm not
dead
you know i'm not dead on a slab yet so
i'm hoping
and plus my brother's still missing it's
a whole thing like that this
i gotta i gotta find the other elicity
baby you know what i mean there's like
there's you know can't have want and
queen children running around the
euroverse
do you get paid for doing if you do like
batwoman flash and supergirl all in one
episode like you're crossing over do you
get paid your salary in each
for each show
i don't remember there's some
i'm interested in knowing that yeah
where it yeah there's there's some way
that they
accounted for it in the contract where
it was like fair to everyone which i'm
fine with you know as i mean i'm you
know me i'm an economist i'm a
businessman at heart but as long as it's
fair
i'll you know i'll take it you'll take
it
you